[Música]
oi eu sou pedro pádula eu tenho 10 anos
e hoje eu vim foi falar um pouco sobre
atitudes e soluções para ajudar a
combater o lixo o lixo é um problema sim
pesquisei muito sobre isso e é um dos
maiores problemas da nossa geração em
geração e das gerações futuras
vocês sabiam que só no brasil são gastos
mais de 8 bilhões de reais por não
reciclar o lixo é muito dinheiro sendo
jogado fora em 2010 foi criada a
política nacional dos resíduos sólidos e
com o objetivo de é aumentar a
reciclagem e acabar com o lixo e
poluição em aterros e lixões e como
podem ver que muita coisa para ser feita
hoje ciclo da vida do lixo é chamado de
economia linear economia linear funciona
do jeito que é assim é o programa terra
prima extraída da natureza
o produto é fabricado o produto é
distribuído
o produto consumido e acaba o ciclo da
dúvida do do lixo
qual é a solução após que você sair na
platéia é já fazem isso
se vocês ainda não fazem vocês devem
começar a separar seu lixo corretamente
senão isso pode acontecer o que podemos
fazer além disso se você não tem coleta
seletiva no seu bairro
você pode levar seu lixo para um dos
pontos de coleta voluntária ela vai ter
alguém para te ajudar essa pessoa é
geralmente de uma cooperativa e
isso é nosso lixo uma fonte de renda
para eles então nós estamos ajudando
ambiental e socialmente
legal né geralmente os pontos de coleta
voluntária ficam em supermercados o que
só trazendo de novo o conceito de
economia circular para vários tipos de
dirigir
no brasil a economia circular funciona
com a extração da matéria-prima na
natureza com a fabricação do produto
com a distribuição do produto com o
consumo do produto
só que em vez do lixo para aterros e
lixões ele volta com matéria prima e
pode virar outro produto
alguns é símbolo de economia circular no
brasil são um deles é o caso da
reciclagem de fraldas pós uso
o desafio era a tecnologia de separar o
resíduo plástico do orgânico ea solução
para o resíduo plástico essa resina que
pode ser transformada em outro produto
e o resultado é de para o resultado para
os produtos vez podem virar banquete
para escovar os dentes ou tomar a sede
de cheias
outro caso é da cápsula de bebidas
outro caso de reciclagem da cápsula de
bebidas é mas não é de alumínio porque é
muito fácil de se reciclar a de plástico
é muito mais difícil
o desafio é ter a tecnologia para
separar o plástico que é resíduo
reciclável do resíduo orgânico que é
chocolate chá e café
a solução também é o a resina essa
resina pode ser transformado em vazios
para plantar café ou por cápsula de
bebidas e só usam para o resíduo
orgânico pode estar sendo estudada para
está sendo estudada há o conceito para
virar adubo
vamos aprender um pouco com a natureza
pois com a natureza nada se perde tudo
se transforma
obrigado
[Aplausos]